today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
so the republican national convention
continued yesterday yesterday was day
two
it was definitely a different day than
day one there was less screaming from
the speakers although eric trump
did a little bit of screaming but it was
sort of a weaker day
from the standpoint of making the case
that donald trump should be re-elected
some of the major speeches yesterday
including melania trump's
said a lot but didn't actually explain
why what they said means or
points to re-electing donald trump and
i'm going to get to that in a moment but
if i had to sort of give a very broad
overview day one was erratic
screaming kimberly guilfoyle donald
trump jr
whereas day two was more
trying to be more precise
trying to be more calm about
the trump administration being a real
administration
a respectable administration and having
earned four more years but failing to do
so and not really making that case and
it also included day two did
some horrible breaches of protocol
possibly even of the law
before day two even started by the way
one of the speakers
was removed from a montage because it
was revealed that she previously tweeted
anti-semitic conspiracy theories this
was marianne mendoza
her police officer son was tragically
killed by a drunk driver
she was going to be included in a list
of speaker excerpts remarks
and it became known that she had
previously retweeted a thread
on twitter promoting anti-semitic
conspiracies so she was pulled from the
evening program i mean just every detail
beyond parody and exactly what
the stereotypes about these types of
events are actually
meeting that standard that expectation
conforming to it
melania trump spoke from the white house
rose garden now
it was a rose garden devoid of roses
very strange
updates to the landscaping made in
advance of melania trump's speech which
shouldn't even have taken place
really the white house not supposed to
be used as a political prop
not supposed to be used um for political
events
and they did there will be no
repercussions
don't even think about it i know it's
frustrating but there's just not going
to be any repercussions for that
but the most notable thing to me from
day two
was the degree to which it was filled
with bold-faced lies
provable lies and this was another
distinction from day one
not only less screaming on day two
um day one more optics and propaganda
that are less simply
factually false day one had a lot of
north korea-like imagery from kimberly
guilfoyle
obviously nonsense but not as many
straight up factual lies
yesterday was just laughable obvious
provable empirical lie after lie and
we're going to go through some of them
maybe the funniest was when former
florida attorney general pam bondi
claimed that what she did as florida
attorney general
was fight corruption check this out and
then i'll remind you why it's so wild
but for joe biden it's been the land of
opportunism
not opportunity as a career prosecutor
and former attorney general of florida
i fought corruption and i know what it
looks like
whether it's done by people wearing
pinstripe suits or
orange jumpsuits pam bondi says
that she fought corruption as attorney
general in florida
she was investigating trump university
as attorney general in florida trump
donated to her re-election campaign
and the investigation went away and she
has the audacity
to brazenly say that she fought
corruption as attorney general in
florida
she was corrupt as attorney general in
florida
pam bondi also criticized joe biden for
nepotism
and then was followed up yesterday by
tiffany trump
eric trump and melania trump again
saturday night live can't do anything
with it it's beyond parody
tiffany trump did speak as i mentioned
she's donald trump sort of less public
daughter um it wasn't really clear it
hasn't been clear that tiffany trump
likes her dad
and it certainly wasn't clear yesterday
but she did speak
she bizarrely claimed that people are
enslaved by the media
and coerced by the media and by tech
giants
very unusual imagery take a look of who
we are
voting for may and are being manipulated
and visibly coerced by the media and
tech giants
if you tune into the media you get one
biased opinion or another
and what you share if it does not fit
into the narrative that they seek to
promote
then it is either ignored or deemed a
lie
regardless of the truth this
manipulation
of what information we receive impedes
our freedoms
rather than allowing americans the right
to form our own beliefs
this misinformation system keeps people
mentally enslaved enslaved i mean really
powerful language tiffany's speech again
it wasn't just low energy it didn't
make the case for donald trump's
reelection and that was what was
interesting about about a lot of the
speeches yesterday including melania's
which we're going to get to
which was that so much was said but
it wasn't clear why anybody should vote
for donald trump on the basis of the
speeches that were made
trump's son eric trump spoke and again
lame lies nonsense but here is
one of the whoppers that eric told just
making
things up out of thin air it's in the
middle east
never ending wars were finally ended now
of course
donald trump did not achieve peace in
the middle east
you probably know that donald trump did
not end any wars
you probably know that it just didn't
happen these are provable
empirical lies we then heard from trump
economic adviser larry kudlow
who showed up and just told a complete
fantasy
about the trump administration's
handling of coronavirus and
in that context of the economy take a
look at this one once in 100-year
pandemic
it was awful health and economic impacts
were tragic
hardship and heartbreak were everywhere
but
presidential leadership came swiftly and
effectively
with an extraordinary rescue for health
and safety
to successfully fight the covet virus so
to his credit larry kudlow didn't seem
drunk this time that's good
but he wasn't making any sense anyway
and of course this administration
did not put together the brilliant
health and economic plan that larry
kudlow
wants us to believe they put together
and in fact
the trump administration response was
one of the worst responses to the virus
in the world
and led to not only unnecessary death
but also unnecessary economic
destruction
they didn't create the virus they're not
responsible for the virus
but they are responsible for one of the
worst responses larry kudlow also by the
way
as many speakers did on day one and on
day two
kudlow refers to coronavirus and the
pandemic in the past tense
you might be interested to know just to
be anchored to reality that coronavirus
killed another
1291 people in the united states
yesterday alone they continue to pretend
that it's over and they need to they
need to and that's why they've been
doing it for months
coronavirus ranks is one of the most
important issues for voters
and one of the ones where donald trump
has the lowest approval rating so they
have to pretend it's over they have to
claim that donald trump managed it very
well
now one of the propaganda elements
that's concerning many people from
yesterday
is that uniformed members of the
military were pulled into the evening
which isn't supposed to happen for
example we're showing video
of uniformed marines when donald trump
did a naturalization ceremony at the
white house for new
citizens marines and members of the
military are not supposed to be
political figures in political videos
and the entire night was filled with
this now the response from the white
house was
these events were white house formal
events
the video was then made public and the
public video was then used at the rnc
so at the time that the uniformed
marines
were filmed these were not
political events but they were white
house events
i don't think i have to say too much
more about that reasoning
another propaganda element was trump
springing a pardon
on a guy after a whole propagandistic
montage
and again donald trump creating
something out of nothing
take a look at this video listen to this
to join us
as i grant john i'm not sure you know
this
a full pardon
so i don't know if you know that jamie
come on over here
it's just an honor and you have done
incredible work thank you sir
and all of las vegas and all of nevada
and all of every place in this country
is very proud of you the job you've done
bringing people back and you're right i
was supposed to be there for five
minutes i stayed for an hour
because it was so interesting to me
congratulations
you really get the sense that donald
trump doesn't really
understand what he's doing but he
imagines or envisions that it looks
great to people
and that they're going to be incredibly
moved by it when it's just
awkward more than anything else and then
the night
capped off the keynote of the evening
last night
was melania trump a very long
speech completely meandering if you said
what was the speech about i couldn't
tell you there was really no arc to it
there was no coherent narrative
and it certainly didn't make the case
for why donald trump should be reelected
donald trump did not seem pleased during
it in fact as we're showing people he
looked like
very much like he was not enjoying
himself every time that the camera would
cut to him during the speech
and it was a lame speech here's a few
moments melania saying that donald trump
this is funny
that trump doesn't play politics and
even she seems to have a hard time
believing that
donald wants to keep your family safe he
wants to
help your family succeed he wants
nothing more
than for this country to prosper and he
doesn't waste time
playing politics now oh yeah what what i
didn't like was
i saw a lot of people supposedly on the
left
for example during my live streams
yesterday ridiculing melania for her
accent
listen she's not from the united states
people have accents
when they learn languages as adults i do
think
it's beneath us to go after her for her
accent we should go after donald trump
because he has one position on
immigration
and then we learn that his wife was
working in the united states at a time
when she was not authorized to work in
the united states that's against the law
we that that's fair game um melania's
parents got
special treatment and became citizens
melania got an einstein visa
all of that is completely fair game her
accent is not fair game for me i think
the left should stay away from that i
think it does absolutely nothing for us
now here melania trump seems to sort of
find the solution to racism in some
weird way take a look
with that in mind i like to call on the
citizens
of this country to take a moment pause
and look at things from all perspectives
i urge people to come together in a
civil manner
so we can work and live up to our
standard
american ideals i also ask people to
stop the violence
and looting being done in the name of
justice
and never make assumptions based on the
color
of a person's skin yeah guys i mean just
stop the violence stop the looting and
stop the racism
oh all right and and then again how that
links to trump's reelection
is beyond me there were some really
cringy applause
lines where it sort of became
clear that people were supposed to clap
but always
like half a beat too late for example
melania pausing
when she said that she became a citizen
after passing a test
and it was just really really awkward
but i wanted more
i wanted to be a citizen after 10 years
of paperwork and patience i studied for
the test
in 2006 and became an american citizen
so again the real critique of this
speech
is there was no coherent story there was
no coherent arc it was terribly written
but more importantly these musings from
melania trump
don't make the case effectively for
donald trump's reelection
now you and i would say you can't
possibly make that case because
he doesn't deserve to be reelected and i
would agree with you
but typically no matter how bad a first
term has been
a convention speech is able to put
together a story
at least plausibly justifying if you buy
into it
the re-election of the sitting president
melania's speech didn't even do that
and quite frankly for all we know she
doesn't even want donald trump to be
re-elected
my sense from day one has been she
didn't want to be the first lady of the
united states
she just wanted to marry a rich guy and
travel from penthouse to penthouse on
trump's private plane i don't think she
really wants any part of this i don't
think it's been particularly good
for her and again yesterday we learned
that she had been uh
she has been caught on recordings
disparaging donald trump disparaging
trump's adult children
it's not even clear she wanted to be
giving this speech
but it is what it is i guess to quote
donald trump
uh tonight is night three we're
expecting scheduled although always
subject to change if someone gets caught
tweeting something anti-semitic they may
be pulled but
we're expecting vice president mike
pence tonight his wife karen pence
uh a bunch of other members of congress
kellyanne conway who recently announced
she's quitting in five days
she's scheduled to speak tonight um eric
trump's wife lara trump
expected tonight so join me for day
three i'll be starting the live coverage
on
our youtube and twitch channels at about
quarter past 8 p.m eastern time 8 15 p.m
eastern
5 15 p.m pacific and
like two in the morning uh western
europe time a lot of people staying up
late with us for these
conventions join me tonight in the
meantime let me know your thoughts
via twitter i'm on twitter deepakman you
can find me there
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they
do is take thousands of popular
nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right today's new members of the day
are anne doyle and
valerie niederhoffer ann and valerie
thank you so much for signing up
also big thank you to david horwitz
who's today's long time
sustaining member of the day membership
it's what's for dinner grab one at
joinpacman.com
today hatred mail does make a triumphant
return to the show
if you don't remember what hatred mail
is here's a reminder
we're getting to the oranges of this
investigation
so god bless the united states america
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
yeah so hatred mail is when a
professional
uh voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail
that i get here is one from someone who
simultaneously seems
just obsessed with me but also seems to
very much dislike me
who is david pakman is he married
and fatard below me is correct women
pick their man i mean she should have
married
you a loser youtube commentator she
seems like she has an okay life
first world problems huh pacman you are
a loser
sign up to become unhinged loon with
pacman
report the news of trump's victories i'm
not a fan
of david cuckhold pakman surprisingly or
maybe not i mean maybe this is actually
a common psychological phenomena
it's really common that some of the
people who seem to
despise me the most because of my
political views and
and the program i host also seem
obsessed with the minutia of everything
i'm doing everything i'm saying my life
and whatever else
it's actually not altogether uncommon
among patriots and
maybe that's surprising maybe it's not i
don't know
but remember that you can fight
patriotism
in your communities by using the coupon
code hatred 40
any membership at joinpakman.com can be
instantly discounted by 40 with the
coupon code hatred 40
the hatreds hate it when that coupon
code is used and it's spelled
h-a-t-r-i-o-t-4-0
okay hillary clinton we've heard from
hillary clinton hillary clinton
says that joe biden should not concede
the election
to donald trump in the immediate
aftermath of november 3rd
under any circumstances until and if it
becomes clear
that joe biden has actually lost the
election there's an interesting new
interview
clinton was interviewed by jennifer
palmieri for the showtime program the
circus
and right wingers are losing their minds
about what hillary said
sean hannity is feverishly tweeting
about it people are going crazy
it's really not a big deal actually what
hillary clinton says makes a lot of
sense
and in fact it shouldn't even be super
controversial let's take a look at it
then we'll discuss
so we've got to have a massive
legal operation i know the biden
campaign is working on that we have to
have
poll workers and i urge people who are
able to
uh be a poll worker we have to have
our own uh teams of people to counter
the
the force of intimidation that the
republicans and trump
are going to put outside polling places
this is a big organizational challenge
but at least we know more
about what they're going to do and you
know joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch and if we are as focused and
relentless
as the other side is so this is actually
good advice
and democrats democrats sometimes are
pushovers
let's be completely frank and there
really is no incentive to concede early
period now people like sean hannity and
others
are pretending that what hillary clinton
is saying
is never concede no matter what even if
you lose the popular vote and the
electoral vote handily
and there's no foul play that appears to
have taken place and there's no
that's not what hillary clinton is
saying hillary clinton is is
astutely pointing out trump is not going
to concede
uh if it's close trump is going to claim
that it's rigged
donald trump is trying to rig it and
planning to rig it
so why should joe biden concede if
there's any possibility that he actually
won
now this could be because of mail-in
ballots that had
have maybe will not yet be counted as of
november 3rd at midnight that's one
possibility
it could be because of other types of
voter suppression
it could be for any number of different
reasons and i was actually thinking back
to the year 2000 which 2000 was sort of
the first presidential election i paid
close attention to i remember i was in
high school and there were
you know you started to figure out who
are the few right-wing kids
in my very liberal high school and who's
following politics and who's not and
i remember paying close attention to
that election it was bush v gore
and um it came down to florida as many
of you may remember al gore won the
popular vote
nationally ultimately lost florida
and when people think back to that i was
recently talking to people who
misremember the crux of what happened in
the year 2000 in florida
a lot of people correctly remember that
there was a recount started in florida
and that then republican secretary of
state in florida
katherine harris got involved ultimately
the supreme court
stopped the recount and the state went
to george w
bush by about 500 votes and when people
think
back now they often think if the supreme
court hadn't stopped the recount al gore
would have won
would have won florida and thus would
have won the presidency
that's not likely the case because
there was a secondary controversy in
florida in the year 2000
the details of which people still argue
about but it was about
votes sent in by mail many from overseas
a bunch of different scenarios a bunch
of different ballots which
were misplaced and thrown out and just
disappeared okay so the exact details
are less relevant
than the realization that in all
likelihood the recount that was stopped
george w bush was probably going to win
that recount if it had been completed
the real problem was the problem of the
ballots that were not going to be
part of the equation that were that were
gone and likewise
in this upcoming election there are
likely to be a ton of different layers
in the subterfuge
including mail-in absentee ballots voter
suppression
voter purges meddling of different kinds
trump trying to use the judges that he
so famously has appointed to his
advantage on and on and on
and so what hillary clinton is
suggesting is not
that if joe biden loses fair and square
he never concede
would hillary clinton is suggesting is
that until it is really
truly all completely said and done and
it is completely clear
that joe biden has lost there is no
reason for joe biden to concede
now i think we also have to remember
because people are going crazy pulling
their hair out about over this as if
hillary clinton hillary clinton is
saying something
crazy remember that conceding is merely
a formality it doesn't matter
whether the the losing candidate
concedes
has no bearing on what happens on
january 20th
and when it might come down to lawsuits
and courts and the opinions of judges
maybe judges selected by donald trump
you don't want to do anything the optics
of which might make it easier for a
judge to hand anything to donald trump
and although conceding is merely a
formality
much like running up the score in the
popular vote
these are optics which might provide
cover for a judge to
rule in favor of donald trump if it
comes down to a court
and likewise this is why i've said we
have to run up the popular vote
you know in heavily blue states like
california and massachusetts there
may be leftists who say i'm not going to
vote they don't need my vote or i'll
vote third party because biden's clearly
going to win california he's clearly
going to win massachusetts i disagree
we have to run up the score make it
harder
for a court to help donald trump in any
way
because donald trump is going to use
every tactic possible
to steal this election joe biden and the
democrats
need to have a specific plan for exactly
how to deal with every aspect of this
ahead of time i'm not sure that they do
now uh let's let's deal just for a
moment
with what the right wingers are saying
again people like hannity and some right
wingers
are reacting as if hillary clinton is
saying
even if you really lose don't concede
that's not what she's saying
she's saying she believes joe biden's
going to win
but that there will be pressure on him
to concede
and foul play such that he might
end up conceding before he's satisfied
that he really lost and that he
shouldn't do that
i'm the first to tell you biden may
actually lose
at least 60 million people are going to
be voting for the re-election of donald
trump maybe 65 million maybe 66
we we don't know but roughly 60
something million people will be voting
for trump's re-election
it's certainly plausible that trump wins
and if that's the case
uh it's not for joe biden to just insist
that he really won
biden will have to concede and i'm sure
he will and it'll be up to us to deal
with the reality
that we have more than 60 million people
in this country who observed the last
four years
and said give me another four that's a
problem we'll have to deal with and it's
a serious problem
but the advice is correct to joe biden
until you're actually satisfied
that you really lost don't concede and i
hope he follows it
hopefully it won't even be close but
there's a real possibility that it will
be
and those close scenarios as i'm going
to talk about friday are the ones that
are going to be mo
the most difficult legally and also the
most likely to lead to violence in the
streets which i don't want to happen
but i fear is a real possibility if it's
close and trump says that it's rigged
i'll deal with that on friday
uh and what is happening uh in the
intervening time now is
everybody's got to figure out how are
you planning to vote
are you voting absentee if so are you
mailing your ballot or dropping it off
are you voting in person
what's the plan is it going to feel safe
how many masks will you be wearing
so on and so forth that's what we can do
in the intervening time we will have
more on this much more on our instagram
page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show and also
last night i got a crazy hate mail
and i posted it to my instagram which is
david.pakman
my question to you is do you think the
hate mail i posted last night
is real or fake take a look at it
david.pakman on instagram let me know
what you think
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
so i really hate that i was right about
this but i was right about this
donald trump and his fda chairman
stephen hahn
dramatically and irresponsibly over
hyped and oversold their announcement
about
convalescent plasma as a coronavirus
treatment and stephen hahn is now
admitting it and of course it really
shouldn't surprise
any of us because they've been over
hyping everything all along
going all the way back to
hydroxychloroquine months ago
now i told you when donald trump held
this completely belligerent unhinged
event on sunday
promoted on saturday as a huge
announcement about coronavirus treatment
the announcement was the fda has issued
an emergency use authorization
for convalescent plasma this was
suspicious convalescent plasma
is a procedure it's a transfusion
of plasma from people who have recovered
from coronavirus the idea being that
transfusing their plasma
into people suffering from the virus
could be
an effective treatment now the reason
that it was suspicious from the get-go
was because there was nothing new about
convalescent plasma so donald trump
making a big announcement and trying to
pat himself on the back as if this is an
achievement
for him or for his administration that
didn't make sense and that was where i
started to think there's something a
little bit fishy going on here and if
you've been following coronavirus for
months the way we have you would know
that convalescent plasma transfusions
have been a
potential treatment for coronavirus for
months
around the world i have uh relatives in
argentina
who have coronavirus and um six weeks
ago
the possibility of giving them a
convalescent plasma plasma transfusion
if they became sicker was a possibility
it has nothing to do with donald trump
and so really the announcement was
the fda is issuing an emergency youth
use authorization the announcement was
not really we now can do this thing
called convalescent plasma transfusions
it was we're going to change
the for the infrastructure from being
able to do the convalescent plasma
within a randomized controlled trial to
doing it
under an emergency use authorization and
that
did not seem like a particularly good
idea for the reasons i told you on
sunday
and on monday including that
it may start to be given to patients who
are less sick and don't actually
need something because they would
recover naturally and there are risks
including
lung injury and other potential problems
with these convalescent plasma
transfusions
also giving
when you have an rct a randomly
controlled randomized controlled trial
uh you're really zeroing out confounding
factors
to try to focus in on
what was the effect of the convalescent
plasma
and when you do an eua and you start
giving the treatment to more people
including people who are going to
recover anyway
it can falsely or deceptively
incorrectly make the treatment seem more
effective than it is
okay i told you all of that on monday
well stephen hahn
the fda's director stephen hahn has now
conceded that yes
it's true he exaggerated the
effectiveness of the treatment
on sunday he doesn't even try to hide it
he tweeted at the end of a series of
tweets quote
i have been criticized for remarks i
made sunday night about the benefits of
convalescent plasma
the criticism is entirely justified
what i should have said better is that
the data
show a relative risk reduction
and not an absolute risk reduction
this was totally obvious all along
and trump's sunday stunt was merely a
stunt to try to take
credit for something that number one has
nothing to do with him whatsoever anyway
and number two shock is not the miracle
that they claim
it is now i don't i guess okay let me
let me do this han also went into some
garbage math on sunday
on sunday hans said the drug appears con
or convalescent plasma treatment
appears to lower mortality by 35 percent
so he said for every 100 people who get
the virus it saves 35 people
that's insane okay now i i has the
reason i'm hesitating is
the math is so stupid that i don't know
if it's patronizing to even do this but
i think it's worth putting on the record
the death rate of coronavirus appears to
be about 0.8 percent
if you account for you know all all
cases
not a case fatality rate but a death
rate let's call it one percent
what that means is that for every 100
people who get coronavirus you would
expect one to die one percent death rate
so if convalescent plasma reduces
mortality by 35 percent
if a thousand people get the virus you
would expect that 10 would die
one percent and convalescent plasma
would potentially save three or four
people right if it's
35 it's 3.5 people per thousand that it
would save based on a one percent
mortality rate now i want to be really
clear
if that's true that's important that's
significant that's not nothing
those numbers are shaky and it's not
clear that that's what it is
but the press release from the fda
containing these claims
was clearly a propaganda document
written by the white house
and when han maybe he misstated and said
from every hundred people that get it
this saves 35
from every 100 people that get it you
only expect one to die so how could it
save
35 when you only expect one to die the
tragic thing is
and if people get why this math is
garbage i apologize for going through
that
the tragic thing is that for many of us
maybe it's obvious
but so many people are still falling for
this stuff um
and and that's uh that's the real
tragedy here you know
dexamethasone tested globally available
globally for months
donald trump takes credit for it as one
of the therapeutics that his
administration has moved forward they
haven't done a damn thing about it
remdesseviere tested globally available
globally for months
part of randomized controlled trials all
over the country
trump tries to take credit if it's
something that his administration did
dozens of vaccines under development
many aren't even american
companies developing the vaccines we the
vaccine that ends up being the vaccine
might end up being from oxford
university in the uk
trump takes credit in advance under his
operation warp speed they are lying all
the time and what i fear is that it will
work
i still continue to think it is very
likely
that we get an announcement about we've
got a vaccine it's good to go
around october 15th won't be available
right away not to many people
and donald trump will take credit and
it'll shift one or two percent of the
vote
and that'll get him re-elected this
fundamentally
is going to be a situation that is dealt
with by doctors
and by public health in the united
states and around the world and it's
going to be dealt with
despite donald trump not thanks to him
and trump trying to
claim heroic credit by saying we funded
production of vaccine doses in advance
that's great multiple countries are
doing that any sane leader would do that
it would be a an injustice not to do
that
to start producing vaccine doses in
advance
common tactic has nothing to do with
trump republicans and trump are trying
to
create the illusion that their
leadership has saved the day
in reality there hasn't been leadership
and as far as having to walk back
you know the plasma stuff um the damage
is already done
way more people see the headline than
see the correction
this is the mo of the trump
administration you put out some
hyperbole up front
people see it they integrate it later
you correct it stephen hahn says you
know i did over
sell it a little bit very few people see
it and it's too late anyway
it's typical it's a common strategy and
it's exactly what they're doing
continuing with unsurprising coronavirus
news
schools of all kinds have started to
open elementary middle high school
colleges and universities
and coronavirus clusters are exploding
now i wish i could say
you know it really seemed like this
wasn't going to happen
we're shocked by this this was it was
just unpredictable
we knew that this was going to happen a
few stories from around the country
at purdue university cases student cases
on campus are already at 41 within just
a few days of students
moving in remember that it often takes
five days to show symptoms
so certainly it's more than 41 cases
that will ultimately be discovered at
purdue university's campus
in florida nearly 9 000 kids have tested
positive in the two weeks since schools
reopened
that brings the total number of cases in
florida among those under 18
to close to 50 000 cases
if you look across the country you have
about 750
colleges and universities now with cases
university of north carolina is a bad
one they've had to send
all most undergraduate students home
already
it's not even september north carolina
had so many cases in the dorms that most
undergrads have
already been sent home notre dame is
delaying classes because dozens of
students have tested positive there
iowa state dozens of cases in the dorms
one of the worst outbreaks
is at the university of alabama at
birmingham
where there are nearly a thousand cases
university of central florida
750 cases i'm not going to give you the
whole list but it's everywhere
and it was completely predictable now i
want to remind everybody in the audience
because every time i talk about this i
get the same
confused emails i am not pretending
especially when it comes to school age
kids elementary middle school high
school
that this is a simple issue this is not
a simple issue you have parents who
can't work if their kids aren't in
school
you have parents that have jobs that you
can't work from home but they don't pay
enough to pay for child care
meaning it wouldn't make sense if their
kids are at home
to go to work and pay for childcare they
just can't work they've got to stay home
that's a systemic problem with the
country
we've not done enough in terms of
stimulus compared to other countries
it is a complicated situation but it is
a systemic problem
you of course have parents who just
insist this is no big deal and want to
send their kids
to school you have parents who believe
you know coronavirus conspiracy theories
you have all that stuff
but the real problem is not so much
parents
choosing to send their kids to school
because they're not worried about the
virus
this is really a systemic problem that
has put
a lot of parents into untenable
situations
now that's different than colleges and
universities
we're talking about if things go
correctly you just need to do remote
learning in the fall
clearly this fall semester should be
done remote it should be done online it
should have been done from day one some
schools did it others have refused to do
it
we're not talking about forever and i
get that if you're an incoming freshman
this is not a fun way to start college
this is probably not even the best way
to start college from the perspective of
learning
i get it but let's not miss the forest
for the trees having to shut
down a semester in progress and send
people home
sometimes days after the semester
started
it's way more disruptive than just
saying hey guys you know it sucks
but we're going to do remote for the
fall and then hopefully in the spring we
can
start to to go back to normal um
spending the time developing a good
remote learning system for the fall
rather than bringing students in
endless testing cases pop up sending
students home
it would have made far more sense
elementary middle high school
i'm not pretending it isn't complicated
the problems are more systemic
than they are individual our federal
government has failed
quite simply the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's talk about something
that i think
probably some people in the audience are
just not going to be thrilled that
that i'm talking about but this upcoming
election
is of such utmost and total importance
the removal of donald trump is such an
existential imperative
that we can't have anybody handing trump
any gift any fodder whatsoever that
he may be able to use to get himself
reelected and unfortunately yesterday
donald trump was handed a gift
as a video went viral of a group of
black lives matter protesters in
washington dc
surrounding and intimidating and
screaming
at a random woman who was just
sitting outside at a restaurant and
demanding that
she raise her fist and show solidarity
with protesters we have video
it's literally video of a mob
surrounding a random woman
and screaming at her this is the
opposite of what we need right now
this is exactly the type of video that
the right can use to criticize
protesters and quite frankly
this is perfect video to help trump if
you were trying to help trump
this is exactly what you would stage and
film i'm going to show you the video
i'll describe it
uh it's a crowd of video it's a video of
a crowd of people with fists raised
really tightly gathered around a woman
who's sitting outdoors at a restaurant
in dc they're so close to her that she's
literally leaning back with her
head almost up against the wall take a
look take a listen if you're not
[Applause]
watching
[Applause]
no peace
[Music]
here's another video a little more
zoomed out where you can see
sort of the bigger picture scene you're
also going to see a protester asking
that white people step forward
i guess they thought the optics of white
people intimidating the woman
would somehow be better i don't know
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
so listen guys there's just no defending
this we shouldn't even i i don't want
anybody to even try to defend it we
we're better off if we just say this
isn't the right strategy this is a
disaster this is stupid activism
this is counterproductive activism and i
know that there are going to be some
people who are going to write to me
and they'll say david you privileged
whatever how dare you criticize this
protesting shouldn't just be when it's
comfortable
if this woman is sitting outside having
you know a 14
cocktail i don't know what she's having
but you know whatever it is people are
going to say
uh who are you to say it's not okay to
make her
uncomfortable activism isn't always
comfortable
uh we don't if we only protested when
and where they
say it's okay we would never get
anywhere
um what i'm telling you is that
this is counterproductive
the woman who was surrounded said later
she's with the protesters she's
previously
marched with protesters but here
she felt under attack these are not only
intimidation tactics they are dumb
intimidation tactics the they are
handing gifts to trump
when they do things like this there's no
upside to this
she was already on their side i don't
know of anyone
who was lukewarm who's going to see this
and say oh
i like now i'm joining the movement the
movement gains nothing from this
it doesn't help the cause now does it
maybe make the protesters feel good in
some way
maybe i'd feel terribly if i was there
intimidating this woman
maybe there are people who feel good
when they do something like this
but it achieves nothing we don't have to
talk about the morality or the ethics we
can just be pragmatists and
and recognize it plays directly into
donald trump's
hands i actually am asking myself
do they care if trump gets re-elected
because there's a reality i don't know
the specifics of of the politics of
these individuals
but there are people who see biden
as just as much the enemy as donald
trump
and if that's the case they may not
care that this type of thing plays
directly into donald trump's hands
if that's the case that's a big problem
it's a different problem
and i would disagree with them and you
know we could
figure that out i i've discussed that
problem ad nauseam for months
but why are we giving people ammunition
what are what are we doing this is
completely counterproductive
and fortunately you know i wasn't sure i
haven't seen everybody's reaction to
this you know people that that work in
my space but for the most part most of
the people who i follow on twitter on
the left who
have tweeted about this uh have
denounced it and that's what it just
needs to be
this is not what we're advocating for
this is bad this doesn't help the
movement
this helps donald trump this is a bad
idea hopefully that will be the
consensus
so there's a guy who called into c-span
after the first deranged and depraved
evening of the republican national
convention
and the guy called in and said said he's
a lifelong democrat
but the first night of the republican
convention has convinced him to
switch his vote and vote for donald
trump now i'm going to play the call for
you in a moment
but what i want to raise ahead of time
is
in reaction to what i'm about to play
for you there's a lot of people who are
debating
is the guy for real or is he a troll is
this for real or is the guy
faking and he's really a trump guy who
just called c-span
and said that he's a lifelong democrat i
have some thoughts about that
but i'm actually going to make the case
that it doesn't matter and i'll explain
why but first let's take a look at the
video
rick and lorraine ohio democrat hi rick
tonight i'm a lifelong democrat i'm from
la reyno ohio which is a democrat city
in ohio
and i just want to say after watching
the convention tonight
on tv on c-span here i am definitely
changing my vote to republican and i'll
tell you what
they just put the democratic party they
started republican party to shame
i'm going to follow the republican party
now but why
what what what was it that convinced you
about tonight
it was the heartfelt way they came
across to the american people
and i was really touched by the number
of times they used the word
god they put god into everything
and the people on the democratic side on
their convention act like they were
pushing god right out of it
and that had a lot to do with changing
my mind
now rick did you say you were a union
member
no sir i'm from uh lorraine ohio
and we are a democratic town here and
have been for 50 years
that's it thank you so much so
in terms of whether this is for real or
where this is whether this is really a
trump guy who's
lying that he's a lifelong democrat the
guy
said that he's calling from a democrat
city in ohio
i've never met a lifelong democrat who
calls
cities democrat cities that's how the
right talks that's
literally a term out of trump's playbook
from the last
two or three years so i think that
there's certainly reason
to doubt whether this guy is sincerely a
lifelong democrat
who was convinced to switch and vote for
trump from knight one of the dnc
uh from the rnc rather but it doesn't
matter
okay this is sort of like looking at
retail versus
wholesale the question isn't whether
this one guy
was really convinced to vote for trump
because of the rnc
someone in a country of 331 million
people with 120 to 135 million expected
to vote
someone i'm sure is going to be
convinced to vote trump
who was previously thinking they were
going to go vote biden by the rnc
the point is the big picture first it's
the big picture of conventions
if history is an indicator conventions
don't really do much for either
candidate
typically what you see is one candidate
has a convention and they get a little
bump
and then the other candidate has a
convention and they get a little bump
and then it fades and by october nobody
remembers it and we've moved on to other
things
the right has tried to make the case
that there is a massive movement of
democrats abandoning the democratic
party
and jumping ship to vote for donald
trump it's not backed up by the data
that we have
there's no doubt that there are
disaffected democrats who don't like the
fact that joe biden is a candidate some
of them are going to stay home some of
them are going to vote for donald trump
likewise there are people who voted
trump in 2016 who are going to vote for
biden
there is no evidence right now that
there are large
numbers of democrats defecting to the
republican party
or planning to vote for donald trump the
one caller
is not really newsworthy but there is
the more interesting and deeper question
about the bigger picture here which is
are people switching parties what we
know
is that most 2016 trump voters are going
to vote for trump again
what we know is that most 2016 hillary
voters are going to vote for biden
what we know is that independents are
leaning towards joe biden
and ultimately this is going to come
down to
who votes in which states and how much
of the vote can donald trump
suppress so maybe it's true that this
particular guy
was a lifelong democrat and he was
convinced after a life of voting for
democrats to vote for donald trump
because of kimberly guilfoyle screaming
on monday night at the republican
national convention
or as he says because the republican
convention kept mentioning god
the truth of course is that in reality
joe biden is more religious than donald
trump
it's not something i care about but for
people who want a religious candidate
there's no question that donald trump's
religiosity is completely fabricated and
fake
as something to appeal to evangelical
voters with trump as a politician
whereas joe biden actually seems to be a
moderate moderately devout catholic
i don't care about that but if you're
looking for the religious candidate it's
not donald trump it's joe biden
uh but sure the caller might be making
it up as well
it doesn't matter if we all go out and
vote period
and uh that is ultimately going to be
the one test it's not
did this guy switch in ohio by the way
ohio
not looking as good for joe biden as it
did before or i guess better said
looking better for donald trump recently
than it did before
uh what matters is if we all go out and
vote and the large numbers and so i
wouldn't be lulled into a false debate
about whether it's possible that the rnc
really shifted a democrat into voting
for trump i'm sure
some democrats did get convinced to vote
trump from the rnc
and some republicans were convinced to
vote for joe biden from the dnc
we're a country of 331 million the big
picture is what matters
let's not lose sight of that and the big
picture is trump is going to try to win
by suppressing the vote
trump's going to try to win by rigging
the election that's the big picture
not whether this guy is a troll we have
a voicemail number
which you can call anytime the number is
2192 david p
here is just an absolutely delightful
caller
saying my metaphor about crawling over
broken glass to vote for biden she says
it literally applies to her take a
listen to this
hi david this is your fan in rural
florida who can only get you on free
speech tv
i just wanted to tell you that when you
said some people would crawl over broken
glass
to vote i burst out laughing not because
it was funny
but because you were describing me to a
t i already voted by mail in my primary
because
i'm 68 years old and i've been stress
eating for four years
so i'm likely to die from the virus but
now
i intend to wear double masks and turn
in my ballot to vote in person
nothing will stop me from voting against
trump
i just hope beyond hope there are enough
of us
keep up the great work david thanks what
a caller
what a caller just absolutely fantastic
and
you know there's the debates over who's
motivated which party is more motivated
or less motivated or what
it's going to come down to individuals
like
our terrific caller who say
i'm going to figure out how to vote
and whether i'm figuratively crawling
over broken glass
uh which includes crawling getting
around the landmines of voter
suppression that are being placed out
there
or literally crawling over broken glass
or what maybe
uh you know understaffed and and
under resourced polling places or
whatever the case may be
wearing two masks etc uh she's going to
figure out how to vote and that's
ultimately what this election is going
to come down to we have a fantastic
bonus show for you
today there's a call from pediatricians
to end these active shooter trainings
that have become very common in schools
and their argument is that the trainings
do relatively little
if there is actually an active shooter
it's such a chaotic situation that the
trainings really don't do much but the
fact that the trainings are happening
may be traumatizing to students and may
be causing them
to live in what is still statistically
an irrational fear given the low
likelihood of an active shooter scenario
i want to talk about that um the cdc
has also removed its 14-day quarantine
guideline for people coming back from
out of state or overseas
and i want to talk about why and whether
it's a science-based decision or
a politically based decision we are also
going to hear
about more of the protests
that are re-erupting we're going to hear
from lawyers we're going to hear from
protesters it's a crazy situation that
is again developing i don't really know
that it's getting the attention it
deserves and we're going to spend some
time on that on today's bonus show so
two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show number one become a member at
joinpakman.com
number two become a patron at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and then reminder you
can join me tonight at quarter past
eight 8 15 p.m eastern
for night three of the republican
national convention i'll be streaming
live
on youtube and on twitch i will see you
then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video